does it bother you that currently you
can't run for president
does it bother who you me yeah what a
question you're asking
if I can't run for president yeah I
don't think it bothers me I think
I think it's not your choice everything
else in your life so far is it has been
your choice
listen some people are put there to help
somebody else do it meaning maybe one of
my kids is going to be a president and
my job is to help change their mindset
yeah yeah maybe I'm a Joe Kennedy maybe
I'm a uh Fred maybe I'm a Prescott maybe
I'm that guy and I'm very comfortable
playing that role yeah because I'm you
know this this is a area I enjoy the
king maker part of the game yeah I
enjoyed the other night we're having a
conversation until one o'clock in the
morning five hours I'm having a
conversation with this guy because I
really think this guy is super capable
of what he can do we've had multiple few
hour conversations sitting there talking
to Jedediah seeing what she's doing
right now our insurance company seeing
what our guys are doing I freaking love
that part of the game oh my God but like
naturally but a little bit oh president
yeah I would vote let me I think you
I'll be honest I think you could do it
let me let me give you one if you're
asking me like what laws I would change
if I was a uh well you can't do a
constitution wise here's what it would
be
I think there are people that love
America more who weren't born here yeah
of course and I think the if you wanted
to really still keep the Integrity of 35
years
do it 35 years from the day you came
here or 35 years from the day you became
a citizen let that be the same as
somebody that has lived here for 35
years I think that law logically makes
sense to me if they did something like
that that law makes sense and I think
being in the military should give you a
little bit more incentive because you've
served and fought for this place so that
should give you another okay knock off
five years he's Gucci that's what I I
mean yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know I mean I know a lot of people that
love America but pets up there is one of
the pro-american pro-capitalist pro so
let's say they change it
let's say it changes the rule what about
it
if they change it I see a smirk if they
change it
I I'm I'll be straight this is the first
time I'm talking about on the podcast
like this if they changed it very high
likelihood I would entertain running
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
Andrew as the vice president
[Laughter]
sit down Anderson Cooper
so that's interesting that's interesting
no you're one of the first guys that um
that I that I actually like that I would
say well I don't want you to run because
I don't want them to just tear apart
your family and you go through all these
things but but yeah I get a good sense
from you that you you genuinely want to
help so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red are black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future look spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]